happy Christmas time holiday season yeah  there is no and we want to do something  special for you guys so we're going to  do this giveaway for December it's to be  twelve days for the holidays so you got  to participate that's right  tell him a big chance Julia so it's  gonna start on December 2nd it's gonna  go all the way to December 13th and then  on December 15th we're gonna pick the  winners we're gonna pick it like a  booger but we're gonna ship out  everything when in the first two weeks  of January because we don't want your  [ __ ] to get lost  I remember we don't want even packages  to get lost in the mail because there's  so much mail fraud going on during the  happy holidays so Mary Meyer Luther King  Day a merry type of pumpkin time so  watch out for all the giveaway details